There are billions upon billions of stars
in our galaxy, but they’re all so far away.
Because of that, we’ve had to extrapolate
pretty much everything we know about stars
from our nearest star, the sun.
At just about 93 million miles from Earth,
the sun is a stone’s throw away compared
to the next closest star.
But despite our relative proximity, we still
have some burning questions about the object
that’s holding this whole 8 ring solar circus
together.
So NASA decided we’re going to walk right
up to the sun and rub our nose in it.
In 2018, NASA will launch a solar probe that
will travel closer to the sun than any spacecraft
before it.
At it’s closest point, the probe will be
within just 3.9 million miles of the sun,
almost seven times closer than the next closest
mission, Helios 2 from 1976.
The probe will swoop through the sun’s corona,
which is the aura of plasma around the sun
visible during a solar eclipse, not the adult
beverage.
It’s able to get within sniffing distance
because of advances in material technology.
The probe’s carbon composite heat shield
will keep the instruments behind it operating
at almost room temperature, even though it’s
taking a beating from the sun’s heat and
radiation.
It’ll withstand temperatures of 2,500 degrees
fahrenheit and light 570 times more intense
than what we see on Earth.
The goal is to solve some baffling questions
about the sun, like why does the solar wind
accelerate, and how can the corona be so hot?
Yes I know, the corona is hot because it’s
near the sun, but it can reach up to over
3 million degrees F, while the sun’s surface
peaks at “only” about eleven thousand.
That weird quirk has stumped astronomers,
but after this seven year mission, they may
finally have an answer.
The knowledge gained on this trip could also
improve our ability to predict solar weather
which would help us better protect satellites,
power grids and future space missions from
destructive solar events.
This probe is not only hot, but a little heartwarming.
NASA announced at their press conference that
the probe has been named the Parker Solar
Probe, after astrophysicist Eugene Parker.
There have been a handful of spacecraft named
after important figures in the past, but at
just shy of 90 years old, Parker is the only
one who has lived to see a mission bear his
name.
Parker’s 1958 paper on solar wind challenged
the conventional wisdom of the time and was
initially rejected.
But it turned out his predictions for the
solar wind’s speed and temperature were
almost exactly right.
NASA’s saying that thanks to Parker’s
influence in the field of heliophysics we’re
finally going to touch the sun.
Funny, you’d think for all the clever people
at NASA like Parker, they would have realized
they could save themselves a lot of trouble
and just launch a probe to the sun at night.
If you like our NASA updates, don’t miss
this one where they announced Saturn’s moon
Enceladus might have everything necessary
for extraterrestrial life!
Are you hyped for the Parker Space Probe or
are you looking forward to another mission?
Let us know down in the comments, and don’t
forget to subscribe and keep coming back
for more Seeker.